now in some senses these are all one
family okay but I like those tables
tables which I hope you've seen this guy
okay
which by the way probably the next video
is gonna be expanded but that'll be on
your HSC you can see down the bottom
there's a couple of extra ones okay and
they seem pretty read and complicated so
we're gonna give them a go now the way
that object is by way of the kind of
question we looked at before when you
have like a real looking integral but
they can say look differentiate this or
give you a function differentiate it and
it heads integrate this other function
than I'll give you okay so let me show
you what I mean
let's try to differentiate this function
it's a bit weird doesn't it have some
faith it'll work out nicely in a second
what are we gonna do this is just chain
rule isn't it actually it's a few
versions of changing but I reckon you
guys can handle it in your head right
what's gonna be able to do right off oh
because I'm differentiating I'm gonna
get F dash on F on time so what's on the
top let's differentiate what do I get
1 is the first thing what appetit
this is really x squared plus a squared
all over the power of 1/2 isn't it ok so
we can treat it as channel we'll just do
our business for the cosmalite kind of
thing
what should i write down first whoo
slow down slow down let's try and do the
steps one at a time we will get there we
got then I would I would probably do the
inside first it's next we should which
is just 2x differentiate the inside now
I can do the outside which means power
comes out the front and then the power
reduces by one
okay so you can see with it the single X
which is some interest or nothing
cultural okay before I move on that's
just the top that's just F - the
numerator I have to do the denominator
as well but that's just half the whole
lon okay great matter speed or curtain
doesn't this tiny this up a little bit
this one nothing much happens to that
here the two in the half cancel it so
she just gonna be left with your ex but
I'm writing that on top because that
minus 1/2 means that square is gonna
come back all right what do I have a
mind you know man that that hasn't
really changed around very much
put it back in radical form because
that's what I suppose all right now what
what can you see what kinds of things
can we do to this to make it better
how the problem is is just there's
factions on fractions flying around
aren't there
okay so what can I do to sort of fix up
the fraction that's on the top what
would you do is it is anyone brave
enough to give a clear answer or are we
just gonna I think it's a fraction the
easiest way to get rid of the
denominator is just a month what terms
by whatever the denominator is right
okay so let's multiply through by the
square root of x squared plus a squared
this is one so it's just going to become
that on that second term on the
numerator the denominator disappears
that's why we multiply here by that okay
multiply the top so we should do the
bottom as well now some of you might
think oh cool I'm an x squared plus a
squared the square root there I've got a
square root there that'll simplify out
but hold on there for a second it might
not necessarily be the most useful thing
for you okay especially learning that
see how my numerator is look at how
simple it's become and we can its
relation to the denominator I already
have so rather than actually simplify my
said I'm not gonna do that I'm just
gonna leave them to factorize oops
there we go done so all I have the top
is just the one over x squared plus a
square that's kind of neat
that's nice it looks really awful to
start with okay so remember I said this
is kind of differentiate and then hence
integrates one of those kinds of
questions right so if the derivative of
this is this what integral statement can
i form of the basis of this working
if I differentiate this and I'll end
here I ought to be able to go the other
way if I integrate this I ought to land
here yeah so I'm gonna write down the
integral off one on x squared plus a
squared with respect to X okay
it's a normal order the integrand okay
the integrator and you'll get this X
plus the square root of okay little bit
messy but it works right now just one
last thing before I leave office like I
said this is all the Taylor standing
rules but this is one which is very
similar okay
in fact the only difference is there's a
minus there okay now let's see how your
algebra is okay suppose this was a minus
minus here what difference would that
make
if I trace my work all the way back up
to the start what difference would you
expect let me push me another question
to help me is that your brain still
training silently in your head answer
you this question how much did the a
swear more specifically the plus a
squared how much did a factor read to
outworking as we differentiated and the
answer is it hardly contributed anything
did it because when you were doing this
part here you know the a was for your
different genders the constants are
vanished right so you didn't even have
it as like a something yet to multiply
by really just kind of sat around and
did nothing you floated all the way
through so if the plus a squared did
that the minus a squared will do that as
well okay the sign actually
not gonna have any effect of this it's
just that that's the number that you say
if I have a plus here that's what I end
up with if I have - all in over there -
yeah that's all now they're right there
there's two separate integrals when your
table sanity was but that's really what
it is don't fuss - here you've got
applause - there - - -